foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to a new episode of RT
Essentials I am Naz Perez and we have
discussed horror flicks on this show and
we've talked all kinds of films about
and starring animals but today we
combine them that is right it is time to
break down animal horror movies now
these are the films that best plotted
humans against actual animals that exist
not fictional monsters or beasts and
they'll be coming at us from Air Land
and Sea so get ready to rethink ever
stepping foot in a pet store or a forest
or a body of water or a barn or Alaska
ever again because this is the best
animal horror movies The Birds
[Music]
thank you
and helping this list take flight is
1963's the birds now this film was
produced and directed by Alfred
Hitchcock and Loosely based on a short
story of the same name by Daphne du
maurier first published in 1952. now the
movie stars Rod Taylor and Tippy hedrin
in her big screen debut and tells the
story of a wealthy socialite in San
Francisco who follows a potential
boyfriend to the small town of Bodega
Bay now they're a series of unexplained
and violent attacks from birds of all
kinds suddenly begin to take place the
birds was partially inspired by a real
bird attack that happened in Capitola
California in 1961 when hordes of
seabirds were dive bombing homes and
cars due to what they later Learned was
a reaction to toxic algae I mean how
freaky would that be
foreign
when it came to filming roughly 200 000
was spent on mechanical Birds although
most of the birds you see were actually
real now like the gulls that were picked
up from a San Francisco garbage dump and
The Sparrows that were both borrowed
from the wild and also purchased at
various Pet Shops the film also had
plenty of special effects which were
spread all over Hollywood to get done
this included people working at Walt
Disney Studios MGM Fox and Universal
International with the final product
containing 370 effect shots but it
didn't stop there Hitchcock also
Enlisted the use of an advanced
electronic synthesizer to create some of
the bird's sounds now the machine they
used was developed from a popular
synthesizer used on German radio in the
1920s which is just such a Hitchcock
move and all that hard work didn't go
unnoticed as the birds was nominated for
a best visual effects Oscar now since
then the certified fresh film has become
iconic in the horror genre on its way to
being added to the National film
registry in 2016. and that's because as
the critics consensus says Alfred
Hitchcock's successfully turn Birds into
some of the most terrifying villains in
Horror history and I can attest to that
fact
Arachnophobia rock and roll
next on this list and creeping plenty of
people out in the process is 1990s
Arachnophobia now this was a directorial
debut for Frank Marshall who wanted the
film to feel reminiscent of the
aforementioned the birds by mixing in a
little laughter to go along with all the
scares haha now the movie centers around
a poisonous spider that hitches a ride
from Venezuela and ends up in a rural
California town why do these always
happen in California it's like they're
out for me where it does its thing and
people start turning up dead so an
arachnophobe doctor played by Jeff
Daniels teams up with a colorful
exterminator played by John Goodman to
try and stop a deadly infestation now
Arachnophobia used a mix of animatronic
and real spiders with over 300 of
bondale spiders hailing from New Zealand
coming over for filming apparently
they're large size paired with a
harmlessness to humans and an unusually
social temperament makes them the
perfect movie stars now one of the
people making the magic for the
animatronic spiders was is Jamie heinman
who would go on to star and co-produce a
popular show MythBusters he was partly
responsible for the general spiders seen
in the film among others
a shot
[Music]
don't mention it now of course the
safety of the spiders was a top priority
on set when something like a shoe was
used to crush a spider a whole cushion
with foam rubber was carved into the
prop any dead spiders used in the film
were those that had already died of
natural causes and the sounds of them
being crushed achieved by things like
stepping on mustard packets or a bag of
chips were added in later now there was
some confusion among advertisers about
whether Arachnophobia was a thriller or
a comedy with some commercials cleverly
calling it a thrillomity which I love
that word it was released to mostly
positive reviews and eventually became a
if not the quintessential spider horror
movie
Jaws I can go slow ahead come on down
and jump some of this
[Music]
you're gonna need a bigger boat
taking a bit out of the next spot on
this list is 1975's Jaws now this film
was directed by Steven Spielberg and
based on Peter benchley's 1974 novel of
the same name Roy Scheider SARS is the
police chief of a small Beach town that
has a killer shark problem and to avoid
a loss of Tourism Revenue by closing
down the waters the sheriff teams up
with the marine biologist and an old
Seafarer to hunt the shark down at first
the filmmakers were hoping to train a
great white shark to use in the movie
but realize quickly that that wouldn't
be an option and while some footage of
real sharks was captured for the film
three full-sized prop sharks were made
instead one was a full body with its
belly missing that was pulled through
the water and the other two were on
platforms with half of their heads
missing on one side for certain shots
foreign
Spielberg and his crew reportedly named
the robotic sharks Bruce after his
lawyer and they cost roughly 250 000 a
piece to fabricate I wonder if the
lawyer costs that much now that was done
with a team of up to 40 technicians
supervised by Bob matey best known for
creating the giant squid in 20 000
Leagues Under the Sea but the big
problem with the robotic sharks which
could take up to 14 people to operate is
that they didn't work all that great all
that often their jaws wouldn't close
fins wouldn't flap and one actually sank
to the bottom this forced Spielberg to
change the way that he shot some of the
movie merely hinting at the shark in
many scenes instead of showing it which
he and others have said probably
actually made Jaws better Anaconda
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
its way to the next spot on this list is
1997's Anaconda the film is directed by
Luis yosa best known for movies like
sniper and the specialist Anaconda Stars
Jennifer Lopez is a filmmaker traveling
deep in the Amazon jungle in search of a
Forgotten Tribe now herner crew which
includes Eric Stoltz and Ice Cube are
eventually lured into the company of a
mysterious man played by John Voight who
uses them to find and catch a Legendary
Anaconda that's worth a fortune Now to
create the giant water snake filmmakers
used a mix of animatronic snakes and CGI
but because the technology was so
expensive at the time every second of
CGI screen time costs about 100 Grand so
the two primary snakes featured in
Anaconda were built with animatronics
the Queen Snake was a 40 foot 5 000
pound model while the second Warrior
snake checked in at 25 feet long and
1500 pounds
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
at one point during filming one of the
anacondas shorted out and totally lost
control although they did get some
usable footage that can be seen in the
film so we'll call that a win and if you
ever wondered what happened to that
40-foot animatronic snake it actually
found its way to the California Academy
of Sciences in San Francisco the skin
and tail were removed to show off its
endoskeleton and animatronic wiring all
in the name of science what's even
cooler is that one of the film's six
Razzie nominations went to the
animatronic Anaconda for quote worst new
star but wait it gets better because the
snake lost the award to the worm as in
Dennis Rodman for his performance in
double Team Deep Blue Sea we're going to
pull together and we're going to find a
way to get out of here
first we're going to seal off this
next up on our list of the best animal
horror movies is 1999's deep blue sea
now this film is directed by Renny
Harlan of cliffhanger and Die Hard 2
Fame and the cast includes names like
Samuel L Jackson Michael Rapaport Thomas
Jane and LL Cool J it takes place in an
isolated underwater facility on an
island where the brain tissue of DNA
altered sharks is being tested as a
possible cure for Alzheimer's but when a
routine procedure goes Haywire those who
are down there become outnumbered by the
Sharks and they have to find a way to
stop them from escaping to the ocean and
breeding with a budget somewhere between
65 and 80 million dollars filming mostly
took place at Fox Baja studios in Mexico
where sets were built above the large
water tanks that had been built for the
Titanic and even though deep blue sea
did feature some shots of real sharks
those Titanic tanks were used for a mix
of animatronic sharks and of course the
space for CGI wants to be added in later
foreign
as far as the animatronic shark goes
director Harlan looked to jaws and saw
that its main animatronic shark was 25
feet long so he decided this one should
be 26 feet and it seemed to make an
impression on Sam Jackson Who later said
he quote was in awe of the size of it
and called it a quote real monster and
for the real shark footage that they did
use Harlan brought the team to the
Bahamas to film with them that included
star Thomas Jane who plays a Shark
wrangler in the film and who described
the experience as so terrifying that I
don't want to remember it now while it
is rotten on the Tomato Meter to direct
to streaming sequels have followed and
deep Lucy has since been regarded by
many critics as one of the better shark
films ever besides Jaws albeit in a
limited genre Blake Placid
foreign
[Music]
you do not want to be nine years old
living in Florida and watching Lake
Placid because that is what happened to
me doing a cannonball into the next spot
on this list is 1999's Lake Placid the
film is written by David E Kelly best
known for like a million TV shows and it
was directed by Steve minor from the
Friday the 13th franchise now Bill
Pullman stars in this one as a local
game warden who teams up with the
sheriff played by Brendan Gleason and
Bridget Fonda's paleontologist character
to try and stop a massive ambitious
crocodile that is Wrecking Havoc around
a small Lake in Maine The Croc was
created by Stan Winston Studios of
course Stan being the legend behind the
monsters in films like aliens and
Jurassic Park no big deal this reptile
measured up at 32 feet long about 12
feet bigger than the largest known
crocodile in captivity at the time
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
there was also plenty of CGI that went
into making the animal even more
menacing including some water work for
when it Dives in and out of the water
and they even see Jade a helicopter that
the Croc attacked when it got too close
to the water the beastly puppet was
tested before filming in Castaic Lake in
the LA National Forest where the
creators learned that it had enough head
and tail function to actually swim on
its own although tow cables were used
during filming to make it go faster
Hydraulics powered the crocodile which
were protected in waterproof housings
and surrounded by a water resistant skin
with many layers of paint to achieve the
desired Croc effect and after all that
work both CGI and animatronic our friend
Mr Croc only got three minutes and 43
seconds of screen time robbery the
shallows
thank you
and hopefully not diving into the next
spot on this list is 2016's the shallows
now this film was directed by jean-may
KO yet Sarah known for the horror film
House of Wax and a handful of Liam
Neeson action thrillers it follows a
medical student played by Blake Lively
who travels to a secluded beach for a
much needed getaway following the death
of her mother but after a great white
shark attacks she becomes stranded on a
giant rock 200 yards from the shore and
she must fight for her life against the
deadly predator only about 10 percent of
the filming was done on location to help
build the setting but most of it took
place in a tank using blue screens for
effects and despite Colette Sarah being
a fan of using practical effects for
past movies the shark in the shallows
was created entirely through CGI which
was reportedly only completed a few days
before the marketing campaign began now
as far as creating the shark goes the
animators were told to think of the
shark as a big diesel truck with a lot
of power and torque as opposed to a fast
sports car
thank you
[Music]
the crew watched countless hours of
Shark Week shows to help sort out the
details and according to call it Sarah
those details included it being a female
shark with a story behind every scar on
her skin for the other animal featured
in the film a seagull named Steven
seagull they considered using CGI or a
puppet but after Blake Lively was able
to feed a group of Seagulls during a
scouting trip they realized it would be
possible to use the real thing the
certified fresh film was a huge hit at
the box office with a critics consensus
that says the shallows transcends tired
shark attack tropes with nasty Thrills
and a powerful performance from Blake
Lively the gray
oh my God
making a colorful entrance next on this
list is 2012's the gray now the film is
co-written produced and directed by Joe
Carnahan and based on the short story
ghost walker by Anne McKenzie Jeffers
who also co-wrote the screenplay with
Carnahan it follows a group of Alaskan
oil refinery workers led by a
sharpshooter played by Liam Neeson whose
plane crashes in the Frozen Wilderness
and as the survivors Trek towards safety
while battling the icy elements and
their own crash injuries they're met
with packs of hungry Canadian gray
wolves director Carnahan studied hours
of nature specials about wolves to
create his pack for the film given that
the Wolves depicted in the gray show
highly abnormal behavior according to
experts the director leaned on more
extraordinary stories like a 400 member
horse hunting pack and 250 pound wolves
fighting grizzly bears
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
now to get the right look for the
animals a combination of trained live
animals large puppet heads operated by
three to four people and acrobats in
Wolf suits were used in the end all of
these elements were seamlessly woven
together using CGI the film's trailer
showed bits of Liam Neeson fighting a
wolf by hand which was originally meant
to be part of the film's ending before
Carnahan later changed his mind despite
some criticism over the portrayal of
wolves in the movie to which Carnahan
replied by saying that the film is meant
to reflect Humanity's internal spiritual
Journeys the gray went on to find box
office success and was nominated for a
Saturn Award for best horror or thriller
film Cujo
[Music]
stick
come on
come on boys
[Music]
don't worry about it man cause your
woman hurt him he likes kids
panting and drooling his way to the next
spot on our list is 1983's Cujo this
film is based on Stephen King's 1981
novel of the same name and directed by
Lewis T who did a couple other animal
themed horror flicks in the early 80s
with alligator and Cat's Eye now this
one tells the story of a sweet Saint
Bernard named Cujo was bitten by a bat
and transforms into a dangerous
aggressive Beast eventually a mother and
her son get caught stuck in cujo's
crosshairs and they get stranded in
their tiny car with the crazed animal
trying to get in now there have been
varying reports on just how many dogs
real or otherwise it took to bring Cujo
to the screen but it seems to be
somewhere around 10 including a handful
of Saint Bernards several mechanical
dogs and a black lives Great Dane mix
wearing a Saint Bernard costume can we
please get a picture of that that sounds
amazing
[Music]
what's the matter
who joked me Brit
[Music]
easy boy
I'm not gonna hurt you
[Applause]
when real dogs were used they would
usually have to have their tails tied
down to their legs because they would be
enjoying things too much and wagging
their tails accordingly and when it came
time for Cujo to attack the car in the
film trainers would actually put the
dog's favorite toys inside the car so
that they would try to get them such
cute Innocents used to create such
horror now the animal trainer used for
this film Carl Miller would go on to
work on the film Beethoven which also
features a Saint Bernard now although
Miller said he wasn't exactly very
popular among Saint Bernard owners after
this movie as he would try to explain
that it's not a story about a rabid
Saint Bernard but rather a story about a
rabid dog that happened to be a Saint
Bernard semantics buddy the fresh film
received a mixed reviews from critics
and it did okay at the box office but
has since garnered a bit of a cult
following through the years and let's
just say Saint Bernard owners have
calmed down
crawl
and arriving on its hands and knees for
the final spot on this list is 2019's
crawl now this film was produced by Sam
Raimi and directed by Alexandra Aja from
The Hills Have Eyes and Piranha 3D Fame
the story revolves around a daughter and
father played by kesco delario and Barry
Pepper who get trapped in the crawl
space of their home along with their dog
during a category 5 hurricane and soon
they have even bigger problems as a
Relentless pack of huge alligators
begins to attack them filming took place
in a warehouse in Serbia and it lasted
41 days using a mix of both practical
alligators and CGI ones with the latter
being the preferred method director Aja
said that using animatronics mostly
locks you into certain Framing and with
CGI they could better capture the
ferocity of the beasts
[Music]
to help simulate the CGI Gators they
would use stuntmen wearing green spandex
divers recreating movements in the water
fake alligator heads on sticks and the
director holding a pole with a pillow
hanging from it wrapped in green fabric
I mean again another image I would love
to see now the alligators were then
digitally rendered and added to the
final product which took three months to
complete with 244 total effect shots
used in the film in order to create the
chaos presented so beautifully in crawl
Aja extensively researched both
hurricanes and alligators combing
through hundreds of hours of real world
footage to find both in their most
powerful forms and friends that is our
list of the best animal horror movies I
mean there's got to be a few that you
were hoping to see on this list so by
all means let us know where and how we
went wrong and if we learned anything
from this list today it said the late
90s was primed for animal horror movies
I mean please take me back thanks for
tuning in to RT Essentials I'm Nas Perez
and I'll see you next time
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]